xbox series s and x storage expansion
details have been revealed
a near replicant remake is in the works
and
nani there's another yakuza movie on the
way i'm lucy and these are the biggest
gaming news stories for
thursday september 24th
[Music]
if you're already thinking about extra
storage for your new xbox
then details on the expansion cards have
just been revealed
the new xboxes have custom ssds that's
one terabyte for the xbox series x and
512 gigabytes for the
s now this should lead to better load
times but those hard drives will
probably still fill up fast
thanks to huge game sizes he is looking
at you
modern warfare but now we know more
about the console's expansion cards
they plug right into the back they add
an additional one terabyte of storage
they're barely larger than an sd card
and they'll have the same performance as
the
internal ssd when you play games that
are stored on them
price-wise they're 220 dollars a pop
that's only 18 less than the series s
itself
now usb 3 hard drives are also
compatible with the series x
and s but you can only play xbox one and
backwards compatible games off of those
that's a lot to take in but we've got it
all written up on site if you need a
refresher
now for more on the xbox series x we
actually have
a fully functioning model that's right
it's not just a dummy one to see how big
it is
it's a fully working xbox series x
michael heim is currently running all
kinds of tests on it
so keep your eyes peeled to gamespot to
find out more
now this next story isn't about blade
runner square annex has revealed that a
near
replicant remake is coming next spring
near replicant version
1.22474487139
is coming to ps4 xbox one and pc via
steam on april 23rd 2021.
the gameplay is gonna be similar to
2010's replicant but with new animation
to match the flashier style
of 2017's neo automata the remake is
being handled by
toy logic who previously contributed to
dragon quest 11 and the evil within
the japanese release has pre-order
bonuses like rubber stamps and there's a
white room version that includes pins
paper scripts and the soundtrack similar
things are expected for the western
release too
the remake was announced as a part of
tokyo game show stay tuned to gamespot
for all the latest from the show
including more on the new monster hunter
games that were just announced
as well as resident evil village
okay i know that the general consensus
is that video game movies are bad
but is yakuza gonna be the one to break
that trend
variety reports that after the success
of the sonic movie which
actually i thought was pretty good sega
is reportedly planning
a sequel for that as well as making a
push to adapt the yakuza series
too they're collaborating with one two
one two entertainment and wild sheep and
a one two one two entertainment
spokesperson said
yakuza offers us a new playground in
which to set compelling stories
with complex characters in a unique
environment that audiences have rarely
seen before
the saga of kazuma kiryu has a built-in
cinematic appeal
a mix of kinetic action with bursts of
comedy multiple converging storylines
and a gripping journey towards
redemption this isn't the first yakuza
movie to be made
prolific japanese director takashi mike
made one in 2007 based on the old ps2
games
no word on a release date for the movie
just yet but the latest game yakuza like
a dragon
is coming out in november if the movie
is anything like my experience with the
yakuza games
this is going to be two hours of that
crane minigame
anyway there are more ps5 pre-orders
going live tomorrow consider this your
psa if you didn't manage to get one last
week
and on tomorrow's episode of generation
next we talk about what has possibly
been the biggest week for xbox ever
you don't want to miss it i'm on twitter
at lucy james games and i'll see you
next time
you